now that our app is showing real data we
should take a screenshot of our app so
we can remember what it was like when we
made it this far I personally like doing
this throughout the process of building
an app because then I can look back and
see how it evolved I'm going to show you
one way that you can take a screenshot
of your device open up Android device
monitor and then click on the device
here then click on this camera icon to
do a screen capture when it pops up you
can hit save and then you're done on
certain physical devices that are
actually hardware keys that allow you to
grab a screenshot for example on the
Nexus 5 you can long press on the volume
down and the power key at the same time
that takes a screenshot it gets saved to
the Photos app and then you can share it
out to anyone you want you can show them
what an awesome app you're building